Celtics coach Joe Missoula watches the
same movie four times a week he watches
the town a four hour and two minute
Boston crime drama movie four times a
week he said quote it's just a Boston
mindset Malcolm Brogden gave a little
insight into missoula's Obsession like
when he wears his sweatshirt with the
famous line from the movie whose car are
we gonna take Brogden explained how
Missoula just wants the guys to have
that exact mentality ride or die for
your guys he said it doesn't matter what
we're going to get into we're doing it
together I mean that is deep great quote
great mentality but four times a week
Missoula